in this video I want to talk about how
exactly we prepare fatty acids for
breakdown so if you want to take a fatty
acid we want to break it down for energy
how do we do that
well before we can begin to actually
break it down we have to activate it
free fatty acids which I'll abbreviate
from now on as fa they must be activated
before being broken down for energy this
is very similar to the idea behind
pyruvate before it can go to the Krebs
cycle and needs to be activated into an
acetyl co a so it's kind of a similar
idea here so we're gonna start off with
a fatty acid which is some carbon chain
right that's our org here this fatty
acid what we're gonna do is invest in
ATP and get this intermediate here this
acyl adenylate intermediate which all
we've done here is tacked on an am p
here and the two this here is a
pyrophosphate hops off right so we
started off three three phosphate groups
and we were left with just one and that
attaches to this acyl group here and we
have this pyrophosphate knocked off now
this intermediate the reason is it's in
turn it is called an intermediate is
because it's used up rather quickly and
a following reaction so the intermediate
here is it's added to a coincidence
right this this portion here that is an
acyl group right so here we have an acyl
adenylate right and here we have an acyl
co a and of course the ANP hops off once
we add the coenzyme a so the overall
reaction here the overall reaction is
that we take a fatty acid and we add an
ATP and the coenzyme a and then we form
this thing here which I've mentioned is
an acyl Co a which is essentially the
activated fatty acid it's very very
similar to the whole pyruvate
dehydrogenase step
to take a pyruvate and turned it into an
acetyl co a acetyl co a is activated for
the krebs cycle now this this a soakaway
is essentially an activated fatty acid
it's ready to be broken down it's ready
to be broken down specifically via beta
oxidation in the mitochondrial matrix so
beta oxidation is the degradation
process right for fatty acids so we're
going to be breaking down this acyl Co a
which is essentially this fatty acid so
what's important to recognize here first
and foremost this enzyme that catalyzes
this step is called an acyl Co a
synthetase and the reason I'm writing it
over this arrow is because this is the
overall reaction here right these first
two steps are sort of part of the
overall process okay so there's an acyl
Co a synthetase which makes sense right
we're making an a soakaway we're making
that activated fatty acid that's what
we're doing it's also important to
recognize that this here this
pyrophosphate right the fact that we
went from an ATP right to an a MP or
just if you look in the overall reaction
we started off with an ATP we ended up
with an EI MP we used two high energy
phosphate bonds because this this
pyrophosphate ends up being hydrolyzed
into two phosphates so this is basically
what happens here is that we're this is
the equivalent right of using two ATP's
so for if we're going from an ATP to an
a MP we knocked off two phosphates since
we knocked off two phosphates that's too
high energy phosphate bonds so too high
energy phosphate bonds right that's the
equivalent of two ATP's
so activating a fatty acid for breakdown
right the beta-oxidation that we just
mentioned which we'll talk about in the
next video activation costs two ATP and
that's an important thing to keep in
mind when calculating the
overall energy yield of a fatty acid of
a particular length thank you for
watching I hope that was helpful video